vengers story trailer don't worry we're
probably gonna watch the gameplay one on
a 25 minute video that probably go up
later today but in the meantime let's
see what they got in store with the
story trailer excuse me if I seem a
little bit out of it started playing The
Last of Us - at around 9 p.m. yesterday
and an hour went by and suddenly was 3
a.m. I don't know how that happened but
every once in a while I'm gonna be
posting my thoughts videoing it on
Twitter so follow me at the greg alba
just posting one yesterday anywho let's
see what Avenger story trailer is all
about
[Music]
hey that's MODOK
[Music]
Donald Blake any big
Oh
[Music]
Wow
a yellow Jamie
[Music]
okay
[Music]
man alrighty let's talk about it I'm not
gonna pretend to be the expert here on
the MODOK character have want to clear
something up and I hope in you guys who
are very much in the know can inform me
properly MODOK is that a later version
of aldrich killian
because an advanced idea mechanics is
aldrich killian x' company MODOK is
running the whole villain ship here I
believe there's something where Aldrich
Killian does beak or like takes on the
form of MODOK something like that this
is my one question as far as this story
trailer goes I'm liking it I think it's
better than what we've been getting so
far the game doesn't look bad I like the
idea of Kamala Kahn mystery Kamala Kahn
being this like cipher for the audience
to bring this sense of inspiration and
wonder through her shoes of like you're
getting this origin tale of her she's
the rookie character who's been imbued
with these new powers and then she's a
big cause for what makes the Avengers
come together wouldn't be an Avengers
movie without the Avengers not getting a
lot of it was like they have to go fight
each other every time they get back
together there's this has a little bit
of reminiscent pieces of like pretty
much all the Avengers movies it looks
like a proper course correction for Iron
Man 3 and an age of Ultron roll out of
like the mech suits and stuff yeah I
think what some people probably wanted
for this one was a Thanos character and
I think if the image of MODOK circling
around
he just looks all purple so it doesn't
like it could just be thinner than that
like really close of a shot that you see
here at the end I'm not sure what it is
that I can't quite put my finger on that
it feels a little bit off about this
game and that's why I want to watch the
gameplay trailer the story looks fine
the music some great maybe you guys can
leave some comments down below and I'll
be like that's it they nailed it right
there yeah but right now I'm not sure do
you have anything off about it for you
gameplays
the story trailer that is specifically
marketing this cinematics is missing
gameplay yeah yeah I get where you're
coming for is weird for me I'm a little
maybe more enthralled by this than you
are but I get where you're coming from
the sense that if you separate it from
the movies like if I'm looking at this
justice like a video game I'm like well
this looks like a pretty cool story it
kind of looks like an Avengers movie
from what they've shown us here and I
like the flavor of that of you know I'm
trying to recruit Kamala Khan and then
her going to reassemble the disgraced
Avengers like I like that set up
generally a lot but yeah like looking
beyond that there's something that like
this could be a movie to me and that's
like the critical little piece I think
that maybe there is like this doesn't
look like it absolutely has to be a
video game but I'm glad that this is the
story they went with because it looks
like it's a pretty engaged story and the
gameplay
you know footage will show us more of
what the actual exterior like I guess
because I don't expect or at least in
the past I haven't come to expect a
heavy high-quality video game experience
from an adaptation of you know a popular
comic book or movie series you know
oftentimes those things are
afterthoughts or marketing employees and
this one looks like it's more engaged
and it really wants to deliver you a
full-on cinematic gripping video game
experience and so yeah like in that
sense it does seem like it's aiming high
because you know I've come to expect
these kinds of games maybe to not do so
as much but especially since the
Avengers is this flagship property and
all that stuff you know it does kind of
feel also similar in the sense that
because you have the thumbnail that does
kind of look like Thanos and then you're
building up to another type figure that
also then yeah kind of harkens back to
some of the imagery we've seen in age of
Ultron and Iron Man 3 there's stuff
that's familiar just as much as there's
stuff that does seem kind of neat it's
not like a 100% like that's the game out
of all the games we've seen trailers for
lately that I gotta get first but it
does look like an Avengers game I would
be interested in checking out for sure I
think there's a lot they have to
advertise in here the game that's being
compared to the most is spider-man and
because that game was it really is
incredible I mean you can advertise like
this story and the
mood of it pretty well because you got
one main character you got to focus on
and then you're introducing all these
other characters around him here it's
like they're having multiple story
trailers and you got to you know
advertise like oh your main character is
gonna be Kamala Khan essentially you got
to introduce the villain and you got to
introduce all the other Avengers as well
or reintroduce them for what its gonna
be like to have them in this video game
I don't know maybe I'm just thinking a
little too much on it maybe I'm a little
too tired yeah also like the previous
footage I will say wasn't as cool like
this is the most engaging footage from
this game I've seen so far and there's
also that too because the earlier videos
I wasn't as in thrilled but I will say
that I really do like about this
particular trailer the first Avengers 8
a trailer was something there was like
all bright and positive and then
something dark happens at the Anna and I
really loved the commitment to how epic
and dark and heavy this actually feels
because you know when you're doing
Avengers you probably just go all bright
color but this one this isn't hot even
like the color and the shading of it
just feels like a really dark gloomy
experience yeah I can't get past the
worst face it just does like everyone
else actually looks pretty good but
Thor's face there's something just off
about it and like with his hair as well
everyone looks really good but something
with Thor's face and his hair just is
not working for me I don't know what it
is but I see what you're saying yeah
graphics have come a long way obviously
but those are typically some of the
places that are most problematic and
maybe because this isn't the most
graphically impressive trailer I've seen
in recent maybe that's part of it maybe
they poured some of those resources
elsewhere yeah I'm sure it's gonna be
fun I'm honestly not as critical as I
can be when I'm playing an actual
videogame a lot of times I end up liking
a game that it seems like the world
doesn't seem like oh my god I thought it
was fine yeah and and I feel like that
could be a very similar thing for me
here especially with you know the
actually being absorbed into the
storytelling that we got and I'm excited
that MODOK
to be the actual villain here video game
villains may be a great video game
villain he's a character that people
have wanted to actually be in the MCU
and to get him here seems like a great
way to unite everyone he's a hard Vil
and I think to nail down for the MCU I
know that some people can easily fathom
it but I could see how in a live-action
format can be a bit challenging but some
bringing him here into a video game I
think could be pretty sweet and that
could be a good place to test it out for
the eventual like yeah action debut
absolutely alright guys what do you
think of this Avengers story trailer or
you have more intrigued by this you
wanted more now than ever has earned
brownie points is it not sway jeer
you're gonna get it anyway even if you
don't really feel much for it or are you
super excited for it yep
if you like this video subscribe click
the notification bell and last but not
least I want a shout out today Rosa
Parra she's been killing it killing it
by following her passion with film
analysis and helping out with the Latin
community as well yeah follow her on
Twitter at Rosa's reviews I'm just gonna
read off how much he's been killing it
okay she kind of film reviewer of
co-founder Latin excellence member of
HEA critics bite site critics film
independent WFC woman the O AFF C editor
at their league hashtag filmed I don't
know how just in a few months she has
managed to do so much I remember the day
she hit me up going I think I'm gonna
start pursuing this a couple months
later she's already doing way more than
us it's an it's incredible you're on an
aggregate review site you say so
Rosa I'm so proud of you and your
children should be proud and if they're
not proud kicked them out of the home
trust me come that's why I'm gonna be a
good parent because I know that I got a
do what my parents did to me when I was
four years old if I'm misbehaving kicked
him out I grew up on the streets Rosa
like Kamala Khan I think I don't know
her backstory he's right and then I
picked him up thanks Rosa